est-ce que vous avez déjà fantasmer sur
un de vos collègues de travail oui bon
mais sorti dû être non
oui d'accord le plus frais le plus
fréquemment louis lui récemment à le
ballet 2
les deux banques a manqué la même
personne à chaque fois c'est qui je peux
pas le dire c'est trop c'est damien
c'est un travail sur l employeur actuel
et ses pattes à bien son valerie jarrett
[Rires]
on passe un shoot dans ça commence
aujourd'hui sur france 2 me direz-vous
suscite le désir
on a découvert s'il vous plaît thibault
je suis dit alors on a découvert
l'histoire de prisca cela c'est une
jeune femme mariée qui n'a pas hésité à
draguer son patron à willard ya eu un
souci un jour avec le directeur et je
les appelais qui dit je peux pas laisser
ça comme ça il faut que j'en parle ou
pas troupe est ce que vous êtes dispo ce
soir on va travailler un peu tard et ce
que je peux vous invite à dîner
donc j'ai dit ok ou dînent ensemble
vernis à ongles et puis la cia ont
toutes été fait nickel j'étais prête et
un moment donné je sens qu'il met sa
main discrètement comme ça derrière moi
auditoire puis après midi peut-être que
vous pouvez leur déposé à l'hôtel ça
vous ennuie pas alors j'arrive avec ma
petite voiture donc lui y était là et
puis je me mets directement au parking
de l'hôtel au sous sol
j'ouvre mon coffre et je sors ma petite
valise mais vous êtes sacrément gonflé
aller au bout en coupe de champagne puis
au moment de partir il me dit bon quand
même je vous en prenez une autre dans ma
chambre j'ai dit oui donc je suis resté
avec lui la nuit alors qu'est ce qu'on
en pense de vous voir je veux que ça
cogite air dans le public ça cogite il
en train de penser à leur patron leur
pas d'accord j'y vais j'y vais pas
qu'est ce que je fais l'amour au bureau
en chiffres 14 % des couples se sont
formés aux au travail 53% des hommes ont
déjà fantasmer sur un collègue ou une
collègue 30% des femmes en déjà
fantasmer sur un ou une collègue et 35%
sont déjà passés à l'acte
un tiers sont passées à l'acte carrément
sur le lieu de travail tant qu'on y est
et on attend qu'un damas bien sûr
ludivine est ce que vous avez déjà
fantasmer sur quelqu'un de pouvoir qui
est votre patron éventuellement alors
vous savez moi c'est pas le pouvoir je
vous jure le pouvoir ça me fait rien du
tout d'accord mais il n'était pas mon
patron à l'époque mais j'avoue que je
trouvais le cyril hanouna variés mais
toujours des années 2000 se trouvait
ultra si vous êtes en train de nous dire
qui est notre producteur de cette
émanation du mans était votre came
mais il était ma came à l'époque où et
montrer ses fesses tout le temps sur
comédie en même temps envoyé lui par
contre il faisait exprès de susciter le
désir on à dakar et exhibe la leur et
nice
allons un peu mais celle-ci ne pas
allons un peu plus avant mais en fait de
votre repas maintenant que c'est votre
cas est ce que justement le fait que ce
soit votre patron maintenant ce serait
un fragment ben oui à jamais à non je
pourrais pas bon non faudrait qui me
renvoie d'accord et sinon ce qu'on y est
maintenant à l'aube à des ballons qu'à
ce qu'il vous plaît chez lui mais jamais
j'ai une témérité on regarde ce qui doit
être dans les loges quelques bars les
départs si tu veux descendre c'est
vraiment je crois que c'est l'une des
plus belles personnes que j'ai compris
tu peux aussi non non non non non c'est
vrai que c'est une belle personne
regardez moi ces yeux et tous ses yeux
sont vraiment le miroir de l'âme à cyril
c'est une très belle personne ses yeux
ok les yeux on note les yeux c'est notre
les yeux on rassure les yeux fait tous
ces fils ims et l'humour alors reparler
de son c'est sous les fesses
donc voilà les fesses les yeux voilà
c'est pas mal c'est possible c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal mais aujourd'hui cyril
tune vous ne craignez rien patron je me
sens très pas de site oui mais qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous est-ce que
d'abord le pouvoir c'est aphrodisiaques
ans sa société mais dans l'absolu le
travail c'est une usine à fantasmes
passe pas parce qu'il arrive toujours un
moment dans la journée on se fait chier
donc voila quand même y penser on
regarde autour de soi pour moi le
problème c'est plus parce qu'avec des
garçons donc forcément je fantasme
vachement moins souvent mais ça que dans
l'absolu mois le pouvoir c'est quelque
chose qui m'attire vachement d'accord
j'ai fantasmé sur quasiment toutes mes
patronne j'ai dit quasiment mais non
mais parce que le pouvoir
vraiment ça apporte quelque chose n'est
pas besoin d'être forcément super beau
mais il ya une espèce
une présence encore un truc moi qui
m'attire beaucoup et d'ailleurs ma
moitié est une chef d'entreprise donc je
pense que ça joue pas mal donc tant
qu'auteur d'un leader qui vaut bien le
côté un peu petit chef
d'accord ça m'excite abbas que je me
levais une manière ce qu'ils sont
entrain de gala au convoi de calmer
tient damien voilà si je prends
l'exemple de notre relation valérie pas
on a une relation je pourrais tout au
mieux partie partagée peut-être un
goûter avec vous mais je ne vous
présenterait jamais prospère pourquoi je
vous ai dit c'est papa présence accrue
en plus à vous dire un truc je vais vous
faire une confidence et mon père
s'appelle prospère je connais un
prospère et battle de danse avec vigueur
pour entre nous par exemple j'ai une
devise mais rob in job je prends plein
air ainsi que la part d'effectivement
lorsque tout va bien on peut entretenir
une bonne relation avec son collègue de
travail supérieur hiérarchique
mais lorsque tout va mal après j'aurais
peur que finalement nos petits plaisirs
coupables devienne un objet de chantage
qu'on c'est vrai que c'est la divine
être dans la même boîte et que le patron
reste patron et vous vous restez un
employé par exemple ça qu'elle a dit
qu'il fallait que j'aie syrie bon on a
posé la question à d'autres les
spectateurs l'amour au bureau est que
c'est possible oui ou non et on nous dit
oui à 76% non à 24% et aventurier est ce
que vous disiez ne parle pas comme ça du
cinquième chronique les continents